bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur lcp public sénat pour
cette nouvelle formule de parlement
hebdo avec michael taref mojo katia
bonjour michael notre invité cette
semaine pour résumer toute cette
actualité politique et parlementaire luc
chatel bonjourbonjour député de haute
marne le président du conseil national
du parti les républicains et soutien
affiché de nicolas sarkozy on y
reviendra bien évidemment tout au long
de cette émission mais d'abord les
titres de cette émission le budget a
dévoilé par bercy cette semaine avec
deux mesures emblématiques le
prélèvement à la source et des baisses
d'impôt de 1 milliard d'euros pour les
ménages comme un budget de campagne le
dossier alsthom cette invite également à
l'assemblée cette semaine le président
était devant les députés interrogés sur
la situation du groupe
quatre cents emplois sont menacés à
belfort et puis on parlera évidemment
avec notre invité de la situation à
droite les candidats à la primaire
fourbissent leurs armes avec une semaine
aussi de cauchemar on nicolas sarkozy
allez on commence cette semaine avec le
budget bien évidemment
et c'est le dernier budget du
quinquennat il a été présenté mardi en
conseil des ministres et détaillé devant
les députés le gouvernement se targue de
remplir les objectifs qu'il s'est fixés
l'opposition évoque un budget de
campagne
rym ben ameur dernier budget du
quinquennat et à sept mois de la
présidentielle il est déjà très critiqué
pourtant michel sapin défend un budget
de sérieux et de cohérence et défend le
bilan du gouvernement
au total nous aurons réalisé 40,6
milliards d'économies entre 2015 et 2017
cette maîtrise n'aura en rien était
aveugle puisque nos priorités sont
financés ces priorités l'éducation
l'emploi et la sécurité
7 milliards d'euros ils seront dédiés
autres annonces la baisse de l'impôt sur
le revenu à hauteur d'un milliard
d'euros pour les salaires modestes mais
bercy la sur la france passera sous la
barre des 3% de déficit comme promis à
bruxelles
je confirme notre objectif de ramener le
déficit public à 2 7% l'an prochain cet
engagement nous nous tiendrons un
objectif jugé improbable par le haut
conseil des finances publiques tout
comme la prévision gouvernementale d'une
croissance à 1,5 pour cent du côté de
l'opposition on dénonce un budget aux
visées électoralistes 1
un budget que nous allons dénoncer avec
un stand de bombes à retardement des des
cadeaux faits à des clientèles
électorales pour essayer de gagner
quelques voix et sauver ce qui peut
encore l'être
l'ailé gauche du ps se prépare elle à sa
dernière bataille dans l'hémicycle
budget c'est quand même ce qui va
marquer la france sur les 1 an et demi
qui viennent
donc ça c'est une bataille à mener on va
présenter des amendements de gauche dans
ce budget là après c'est clair qu'il
faut avoir le l'honnêteté intellectuelle
de dire que fin décembre les sauts sont
terminées principales réformes de ce
budget la mise en place du prélèvement à
la source dès le 1er janvier 2018 qui
devrait donner lieu à des débats animés
alors luc chatel une question peut-être
sur cette mesure emblématique qui sera
inscrit dans le
budgété cette année la peau à la source
pour tous est ce que c'est une bonne
mesure est ce que si la droite revient
au pouvoir elle la gardera où elle
l'abolir à la supprimera parce que c'est
une fausse bonne idée
effectivement quand on en parle comme ça
ça peut être séduisant les français
peuvent se dire et d'ailleurs je lis
qu'ils sont majoritaires à penser que
c'est une bonne idée et bah oui parce
qu'on leur explique pas exactement
comment ça fonctionne l'impôt à la
source
je pense que c'était une fausse bonne
idée parce que au moment où vous
expliquer aux entreprises que vous
voulez leur simplifier la vie et que ce
qui bride sans doute la croissance c'est
l'excès de complexité de formalités
administratives de contraintes
vous allez en ajouter une supplémentaire
c'est à dire que vous allez demander aux
entreprises de faire le travail le
ministre a supris fiscale pour rien dire
est pas pour ça que les tracés pour les
entreprises mais côté déménager pour les
entreprises c'est un vrai problème parce
que ça va à nouveau ajouté de la
complexité
deuxièmement les français à juste titre
quand il en a un poil à sourcils débat
c'est bien j'aurais pu rien à faire
d'abord je rappelle que depuis quelques
années les français n'ont pas grand
chose à faire parce que l'immense
majorité d'entre eux qui étaient
salariés
eh bien ils reçoivent une déclaration
préremplie et ils ont déjà les
informations qui figurent sur la feuille
d'impôt gens qui n'ont pas grand chose à
faire pour leurs déclarations
mais ce que les français ne savent pas
c'est qu'ils devront continuer à remplir
les déclarations serre si vous avez une
multitude de revenus si vous cumulez des
revenus de salariat avec des revenus
immobiliers par exemple du patrimoine
eh bien vous devrez remplir une
déclaration donc je parle de la
complexité ne pas le rappeler on va pas
simplifier la vie des français donc
c'est typiquement l'exemple de là vous
aviez d'accord elle alors dernier
élément jeu souple
nous soupçonnons les socialistes de
vouloir avancer masqué sur quelque chose
de très pervers qui serait la fusion de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de la csg
la csg et et c'est là le plus large
possible c'était une promesse de
campagne non exécutées on a pris
l'habitude en tout cas chaque année il
ya eu des amendements et même le
gouvernement n'était pas d'accord avant
ses marques en fait une promesse de cole
parce que
l'âge pas dans l'impôt sur la fois la
source
alors qu évidemment que la mise en place
d'un impôt à la source permettrait de
rendre plus simple cette fusion entre
csg et impôt sur le revenu
nous sommes défavorables parce que la
csg c'est un impôt proportionnel et la
rendre progressive si on la fusionner
avec l'impôt sur le revenu bien à
nouveau
ça ferait que les classes moyennes les
classes moyennes supérieures qui sont
déjà surtaxés qui payent pour tous les
autres eh bien elle serait à nouveau sur
taquin milliards d'euros de baisses se
sont prévues pour les ménages les plus
modestes
est-ce que c'est raisonnable pour vous
c'est une blague c'est une blague et
l'écouté pensez vous que les français
qui nous écoutent pas vous croient pas
vous mais croit le gouvernement y voit
leur électricité augmente et il voit la
taxe sur l'impôt augmenté sur le pétrole
augmenter l'an l'essence et voit la taxe
sur le gaz augmenter et on leur tend une
baisse d'impôts de 1 milliard alors
qu'ils ont été surtaxés
depuis quatre ans de 45 milliards voilà
donc c'est ça suffise l'aï les arts
d'euros c'est pas suffisant pour vous la
droite propose bien plus nous proposons
nos un contre choc fiscal oui mais
finançons fiscale assure financer
financer par des baisses de dépenses
massives 100 milliards d'économies
et qu'on ne me dise pas c'est pas
possible 100 milliards d'économies ça
représente 20 milliards d'effort par an
je rappelle que le niveau de la dépense
publique en france c'est 1200 milliards
d'euros donc 20 milliards d'économies
sur 1200 milliards de dépenses à
représente 1 6% qu'elle est je termine
le ménage qui nous écoutent les français
qui nous écoutent les entrepreneurs qui
nous écoutent qui ne sont pas capables
de réaliser 1,6 % d'économies voilà donc
ça va être difficile mais ça va être
nécessaire indispensable on doit baisser
les dépenses pour pouvoir baisser les
impôts pour permettre à la fois de
redonner un bol d'oxygène aux français
nicolas sarkozy propose par exemple 10%
de baisse d'impôt sur le revenu mais
surtout pour améliorer la compétitivité
des entreprises
en baissant les charges sur l'emploi en
baissant le la création du capital ce
qui ont favorisé l'investissement et en
supprimant un impôt qui est absurde et
fait fuir les investissements qui est
l'impôt sur le patrimoine s'étaient
alliés de chacun puisque vous parlez du
programme des propositions nicolas
sarkozy voilà ce que vous répond le
secrétaire d'état en charge du budget il
s'appelle christian et cap écoutez vous
parler d'échec en matière de comptes
publics puisque c'était le sens de votre
question
souvenez vous un déficit public au rôle
est l'un des 5 % au-delà des 5% dans les
années 2011 c'est à dire avant notre
arrivée aujourd'hui ramené cette année à
3.3 qui est pas loin de la moitié de ce
que nous avons trouvé en arrivant et ce
déficit a concerné du moins sa réduction
a concerné l'ensemble des secteurs de
l'économie et nous l'avons fait michel
sapin l'a rappelé tout à l'heure à un
rythme qui n'a pas obérer les capacités
d'investissement qui n'a pas obérer les
capacités de croissance qui n'a pas eu
d'effets récessif
alors ça c'est pour ce que vous
répondrez sur les quatre la question
aussi qui va de pair si vous arrivez au
pouvoir vous avez fait il est des faits
filer les déficits
et ça c'est surprenant peut-être de la
parure adroitement nous n'avons pas
réussi les phillies et je veux répondre
à la crise tient à coeur parce
qu'écouter c'est vraiment de la petite
politique politicienne
monsieur kert oublie sans doute parce
que françois hollande l'a répété pendant
toute la campagne de 2012 qui a eu juste
une crise en 2008-2009 qui a fait que
les recettes se sont arrêtés je rappelle
que les recettes fiscales ont été chacun
se connaît ou de l'héritage vous êtes
d'accord mais cette fois qu'on a fait ça
c'est une question qui a eu la plus
grande dépression de l'économie mondiale
depuis 1929 et vous avez 30 % des
recettes fiscales qui ont disparu du
jour au lendemain
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire la france
a fait moins de 5 de croissance je
rappelle en 2000 2009 l'allemagne a fait
moins 5%
voilà moi ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que en allemagne vous avez un taux
de croissance qui pendant quatre ans a
été 30 % supérieur à celui de la france
que la grande bretagne a fait un taux de
croissance du double suite la france et
canards zahlé et que aujourd'hui
monsieur eckert s'envoient des
satisfecits
je constate que l'allemagne elle est en
excédent budgétaire et bien bon nous on
continue à avoir un niveau de déficit
qui est au delà de ce que nous avons
promis à la commission européenne
renonce et la droite revient pour voir s
qu'elle respectera intégralement ses
engagements budgétaires
elle sera sous la barre des 3% de encore
une fois je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
avons prévu un effort sans précédent
dans la maîtrise de la dépense publique
ça va être difficile j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais c'est des mesures très
importantes sur l'allongement de la
durée de départ à l'âge de départ en
retraite sur la suppression massive
important 300000 d'un nombre de
fonctionnaires sur des économies
massives sur le système de protection
sociale à la fin 100 milliards
d'économies qui sont indispensables
alors on avance l'image forte à
l'assemblée cette semaine c'était le pdg
d'alstom devant la représentation
nationale
ils étaient auditionnés par les députés
de la commission des affaires
économiques et il s'est expliqué
longuement sur la stratégie du groupe
alors que le site de belfort est menacée
compte rendu de françois molins la
première prise de parole lors des
questions au gouvernement concerne
alstom et l'avenir du site de belfort en
mai 2015 emmanuel macron était venu à
belfort pour nous assurer de la
pérennité du site et 18 mois après on
nous annonce sa fermeture
vous êtes engagé avec le président de la
république à sauver le site alstom de
belfort
nous prenons acte de vos déclarations
mais nouveau le plomb maintenant des
décisions concrètes et plus seulement
des belles paroles
le secrétaire d'état qui travaille sur
un plan de sauvetage des 400 emplois
menacés affiche son optimisme
nous sommes absolument déterminés à
maintenir une activité ferroviaire sur
le site de belfort
le premier enjeu pour le site de belfort
c'est de maintenir la charge de
production et de donner de la visibilité
avec la prédication du tgv du futur qui
débutera en 2021
le deuxième enjeu c'est de diversifier
l'activité pour pérenniser le site
c'est également un travail sur lequel
nous sommes engagés en attendant les
solutions envisagées par l'exécutif
la majorité se dit confiante moi je
crois qu'il est possible d'avancer parce
qu'il ya les grands appels
en cours et sur lesquelles
ce qui repasse hommes
ce tome était bien positionné et aura
matière à fournir du travail à ses
salariés l'opposition de son côté appels
à plus de fermeté
il ya un moment où l'état doit taper sur
la table
faire jouer les clauses d'exceptions et
mettre les investissements tout en
exigeant que la boîte change de
management parce que quand on est
actionnaire et qu'on a décollé
l'imprévision pareil
on attend que ça se passe non les
annonces concrètes du gouvernement
devrait avoir lieu avant mardi prochain
françois hollande a promis de maintenir
le site de belfort et d'y préserver les
emplois
alors effectivement le dossier alstom a
fait l'objet de nombreuses questions
notamment marc dès lors lors de la
séance de questions d'actualité
une question simple faut-il pour vous
luc chatel sauver à tout prix
alston faut-il faire preuve de
patriotisme économique
mais vous savez la difficulté d'alstom
sont pas nés ces derniers mois en fait
c'est une difficulté structurelle c'est
elle est l'aînée du manque
d'investissement de cette société en
france ou pourquoi est ce que ses
actionnaires et la direction ont fait le
choix de désinvestir tout simplement
parce que la france n'est pas assez
compétitive mais aujourd'hui ce que
c'est une priorité le sauvetage des
dalles et bien sûr c'est une priorité
mais je ne suis pas sûr que l'état
actionnaire soit le meilleur des
gestionnaires voilà quand j'entends
parler d' état stratège
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
depuis quelques années l'état il a été
tout sauf stratège quand je vois quand
je vois monsieur macron qui expliquait
que qui a empêché la fusion par exemple
entre bouygues et orange
c'est une absurdité quand je vois que
monsieur macron s'est permis de faire un
bras d'honneur aux japonais partenaire
de renault en montant de manière
forcenée dans le capital de renault ce
qui a coûté très cher à l'état à des
actions qui peut pas revendre
aujourd'hui de dire on voit bien que ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que l'état
et feront souvent de mauvaises décisions
l'état il doit être là pour faciliter la
création d'emplois pour aider à
l'investissement
quand vous prenez je reviens sur le
sujet précédent c'est le même sujet
quand vous prenez des décisions comme la
prix françois hollande en 2012 qui
consiste à taxer le capital au niveau du
travail au fait fuir les investisseurs
le centre de décision d'alstom il est
parti il est parti aux états unis en
partie donc nous proposons nous de faire
une stratégie de l'offre c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que la france redevienne
un pays d'investissement que au niveau
de la taxation sur le capital on soit au
niveau de la moyenne oubliez ça
s'imposait
européenne par exemple 5e permettre à
des investisseurs de manière
structurelle de revenir en france
ensuite nous proposons une stabilité
fiscale c'est plus possible que le
gouvernement fasse le contraire
en début de mandature en fin de
mandature de ce qu'il a fait en début de
mandature et les allers retours
d'un côté on dit bah tiens on va faire
un crédit d'impôt et de l'autre on nous
ressort pour envoyer un petit message à
la gauche de la gauche
une taxation sur les hauts revenus mais
on y perd son latin
les divers maux qui n'a pas forcément
très bien marché mais il résister plutôt
favorable à sam ou non non nous sommes
favorables à des baisses immédiate le
crédit d'impôt c'est un machin inventé
par des technocrates pour essayer
d'empêcher l'état de payer voilà c'est à
dire que on vous explique que vous
pouvez dépenser et le média radio
centaine de voyages nous nous sommes
favorables à une baisse immédiate du
coût du travail
voilà l'état ils feront tout de suite la
responsabilité c'est simple c'est direct
c'est d'application immédiate
le crédit d'impôt on dit aux entreprises
allez-y vous pouvez investir vous pouvez
payer vos charges mais ne vous inquiétez
pas on voulait remboursera dans deux ans
et en général comme l'étape à l'argent
il est capable de créer un impôt pour se
permettre de rembourser le crédit de
deux ans avant voilà c'est en général
comme ça que ça se passe ces crédits
d'impôt
luc chatel va quitter un peu de
problèmes économiques et du budget etc
je voudrais vous parler un petit peu de
ce qui se passe dans cette campagne
aujourd'hui notre invité de notre mythe
et du scan tout à l'heure va nous
rejoindre mais avant d'en arriver à là
je voulais vous proposer cet ami qui
était réalisée dans le figaro par
françois fillon
il sort un livre en ce moment sur
l'islamisme ça comme ça comment vaincre
le totalitarisme islamique
il déclare dans cette interview au
figaro il n'y a pas de problème
religieux en france il ya un problème
lié à l'islam
êtes vous d'accord avec françois fillon
je ne présenterai pas le sujet de cette
manière voilà je pense pas que le
problème soit lié à l'islam il ya une
immense majorité de musulmans qui vivent
de manière apaisée en france non le
problème il est lié à l'islam radical
radicalisation qui n'est pas un problème
d'ailleurs franco-français qui est un
problème qui touche l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux et qui touche également à la
source dans certains pays arabes qu'il
n'y a pas de problème avec l'islam il ya
un problème avec l'islam radical
voilà choses ne changeront pas sur les
mots on le voit bien et notre devoir à
nous les républicains c'est de proposer
aux français une politique alternative
en la matière d'être beaucoup plus ferme
sans un certain nombre de sujets d'être
beaucoup plus ferme sur la
radicalisation de la société d'être
ferme sur les valeurs de la république
sur la laïcité ça veut dire des
accommodements pas non ça veut dire ça
veut dire par exemple des interdictions
de signes ostentatoires vous savez j'ai
été confronté à ces sujets quand émises
l'éducation nationale j'ai été beaucoup
critiqué à l'époque parce que j'avais
interdit le voile pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire je les fais à
la demande des directeurs d'école des
directeurs d'école qui étaient des bons
laïcards et qui m'ont dit la république
et testé nous sommes testés en
permanence monsieur le ministre
réagissait je les fais eh bien je suis
fier d'avoir pressé dit certains ont
craqué je regrette que mon successeur
que l'actuel ministre de l'éducation
nationale n'appliquent pas cette
circulaire
contrairement à ce que le président de
la république lui a demandé certaines
pratiques sont incompatibles avec la
république certaines pratiques
religieuses pour vous sont accompagnés
en tout cas certaine il y a des règles
de vivre ensemble ce que la religion
catholique a accepté au début du 20e
siècle et bien il est normal que les
autres religions leurs visions juive l'a
fait que la religion musulmane
l'acceptent aujourd'hui voilà donc il
s'agit pas de braquer les uns contre les
autres
l'immense majorité des musulmans sont
d'accord avec cela
ils sont les premières victimes de cette
radicalisation simplement nous devons
ensemble créer un nouveau vivre ensemble
en appliquant les règles de la laïcité
et de la république et on va passer à
notre parti politique avec notre
partenaire le scan
nous avons l'arrivée de jim j'ai raté je
vous propose de regarder ce sujet avec
cette semaine un petit peu cauchemar
pour nicolas sarkozy
la maison brûle depuis lundi le candidat
à la primaire ait l'air nicolas sarkozy
vite un début de semaine cauchemardesque
un de ses plus proches bernard squarcini
ex patron du renseignement intérieur a
été placé en garde à vue pour trafic
d'influencé autre coup dur
les révélations de mediapart sur le
financement par la libye de sa campagne
présidentielle de 2007
à cela s'ajoute le livre de son ancien
conseiller patrick buisson dans lequel
il déballe tout et règle ses comptes
avec nicolas sarkozy mais chez les
sarkozystes on constate l'ascension du
championnat nicolas sarkozy est en
campagne
il n'a pas de gourou il n'a pas de
conseillers jalil a pas de plumes et
bien c'est une et pourtant ça marche de
mieux en mieux
bref tout va bien mais pas suffisamment
pour convaincre hervé mariton
le candidat malheureux à la primaire
faute de parrainages a annoncé son
soutien à alain juppé sans doute le
député de la drôme à tignes miser sur
l'avenir il y a bien sûr chez tous les
candidats qui en particulier
n'arriveront pas en tête l'idée que la
primaire ça sert aussi éventuellement un
casting gouvernemental pour la suite
hervé mariton a senti le vent tourner ou
simplement lui le dernier sondage dans
lequel alain juppé creuse l'écart avec
39% des intentions de vote quand nicolas
sarkozy perd du terrain pour retomber à
33 % ce qui arrive à nicolas sarkozy
fragilise énormément son image et faire
exister
l'anti sarkozysme qui est la latte en
quasi explicite même aujourd'hui dans la
population française jusqu'au coeur de
l'électorat de la droite et du centre
après une entrée en campagne couteau
réussi nicolas sarkozy traverse
aujourd'hui clairement une zone de
turbulences
nous accueillons sur ce plateau d'hymes
géré assez bons journaux trond est
claire je voulais aller avec du chat est
notamment également bonjour luc chatel
on l'a vu dans le sujet que l'on
convient de visionner ça a été une
semaine noire pour nicolas sarkozy la
dynamique coc semble-t-il un peu tassée
après son entrée en campagne et sur le
front des affaires rien ne se calme on a
entendu hier jean françois copé dans
l'émission envoyé spécial consacré à la
sphère bygmalion avec qui a eu des mots
assez durs sur nicolas sarkozy et son
entourage
est-ce que c'était la goutte d'eau qui
avait qui peut faire déborder le vase
cette semaine josé personne n'est dupe
sur cette salle qui est très organisée
et derrière tout ça tout ça n'est pas le
fruit du hasard
personne aucun français de pense que
cette accumulation de sujets qui sortent
la même semaine est le fruit du hasard
raison des départs qui par un mouvement
politico médiatique qui a décidé de
s'attaquer à nicolas sarkozy voilà c'est
très précisément tout cela ça veut dire
des médias s'est trouvée pas qu'ils ont
dû à un adversaire de très pas curieux
qu'elle ait des affaires qui sortent ça
fait trois ans qu'elle existe
comme par hasard on les sort au moment
de la primaire
au moment où nicolas sarkozy est en
train d'avoir une dynamique a aussi un
processus judiciaire est en cours
bien sûr d'ailleurs on attende nations
prévu le tout servi c'est ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que l'agitation
microcosmique de la semaine tranche avec
le calme la détermination la sérénité de
nicolas sarkozy et plus on fait ça plus
il sort déterminé et plus j'entends ma
sur le terrain qui sort renforcée moi je
vois la différence
plus on fait ça plus il ya une
exaspération qui monte dans l'opinion de
droite en 10 ans mais ça suffit
t on a eu droit à une semaine dans le
service public j'aimerais extraordinaire
vous avez en moins de huit jours
l'émission avec nicolas sarkozy où il
est interrogé d'une manière quand même
assez curieuse ensuite vous avez droit à
monsieur buisson à la télévision et qui
est monsieur buisson pour être
interviewé huit minutes au journal de 20
heures de france télévisions c'était
juste
le banni de tous mais les journalistes
aux bien pensants pendant des années
vous notez bien le vip et perdre aux
médias vous n'y a que le service public
est dans le viseur a dans le viseur
nicolas sarkozy mais écoutez regardez le
reportage hier soir on a quand même oser
comparer dans une image le dernier
meeting de nicolas sarkozy avec des tas
de drapeaux des lumières et autres et le
pauvre petit meeting du candidat
socialiste avec un micro bringuebalant
c'est ça les digues du service public la
source et sa l'objectivité de
l'information l'avons mis en avant par
note bravo le service public envoyé
spécial avait aussi réalisé un sujet
quasiment similaire sur la sphère
cahuzac
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une selon vous
une malveillance de la part du service
public sur le t elle et elle est
évidente elle est évident quand on
regarde la semaine qui s'est passé
encore une fois vous allez nous nous
sommes en campagne
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
l'avenir de la france ce qui nous
intéresse c'est les problèmes des
français donc nicolas sarkozy les dans
son couloir il continue rien ne pourra
l'arrêter
voilà il est au contact des français il
fait trois ou quatre déplacements par
semaine
ce week-end il est en vendée il va
repartir en campagne
aastra ans en alsace en jambes bien
rameurs lundi vous parlez de couloirs de
course
la gazelle juppé échappe aux lions
sarkozy ça vous fait réagir
oui on verra à la fin commence et finit
sur la ligne d'arrivée j'ai rarement vu
la gazelle manger le lion parlons un peu
de stratégie politique
est-ce que vouloir dominer l'agenda
comme a semblé vouloir le faire nicolas
sarkozy c'est vraiment la bonne méthode
on voit qu'à mesure que nicolas sarkozy
a multiplié les sorties un peu
provocatrice
au final c'est l'électorat centriste qui
se mobilisent et ça pourrait être un peu
les faiseurs de rois de cette élection
est ce que c'était vraiment la bonne
stratégie
moi je ne crois pas du tout à cela voilà
moi je crois qu'il ya un électorat de la
droite et du centre qui a envie de
s'exprimer qui on a donné la parole
c'est un choix que c'est compliqué à
organiser une primaire c'est un
événement très important je crois que y
aura beaucoup de votants je crois pas du
tout aux spéculations en disant moins il
y aura de votants plus ce sera un test
c'est sur l'île aura devant tant que
c'est son hôtel voilà mais le centre
s'en excuser moi on parle beaucoup du
centre dont je rappelle que le centre il
est déjà pour en grande partie aux
républicains
nous avons des personnalités issues de
l'ancienne udf j'en fais partie les
allées bien à cette primaire mais là
c'est la primaire de la droite et du
centre
donc ceux qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de la droite et du centre
j'avais du temps à autre les roues par
exemple à écouter le centre qui a
installé françois hollande à l'elysée
c'est pas exactement le centre qui
partage les orientations qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui l'important c'est le
centre d'alain juppé et ça sera un bon
débat pendant la campagne qui s'ouvre et
les débats télévisés qu'elle rivalise
ouvriront pas de savoir avec qui on
souhaite gouverner demain voilà avec
françois bayrou
et moi j'ai entendu monsieur bayrou qui
est toujours se drape derrière les tic
et derrière la constance depuis 20
années faire référence aux propos de
monsieur buisson qui n'est qu'un
délateur
c'est quand même assez curieux quoi on a
parlé des acteurs centriste quid des
électeurs de gauche on vois qu'alain
juppé ne manque jamais une occasion de
draguer un peu les déçus du hollandisme
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils peuvent se
mobiliser en sa faveur
le vin moi je crois que ce sera marginal
voilà je crois que cette primaire à lui
être celle de la ce a rendez vous
politique des électeurs de la droite et
du centre
une élection à 4 tours nous sommes au
premier tour de cadres il y aura un
temps où il faudra rassembler les
français ou allemand l'ifo grâce à ses
atouts les français ou dans toute
élection
on doit un peu mordre sur le camp
adverse bien sûr nicolas sarkozy en 2007
il a été élu en primaire oui c'est long
mais c'est non non c'est pas trop long
c'est indispensable
imaginez une seconde que on est choisi
l'ancien système en effet comme avant
c'est à dire que le bureau politique des
républicains est choisi son candidat
immédiatement il y aurait eu des
contestations il y aurait eu une perte
de légitimité y aurait eu d'autres
candidats la primaire c'est l'assurance
deuxième tour assez l'assurance qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul candidat au premier
tour et donc que nous serons qualifiés
pour le deuxième tour
on va passer à un autre sujet il ya une
image aujourd'hui on nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande monte à de nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande ils vont
passer 8 heures dans un avion dans un
petit falcon côte à côte pour aller se
rendre aux obsèques de shimon peres
l'ex-président israël
jérusalem on a l'impression qu'on les a
déjà vus dimanche dernier pour l'hommage
aux harkis ils sont inséparables en ce
moment on a l'impression qu'ils rêvent
de s'affronter ce n'est pas en ce moment
c'est qu'en ce moment ça vous intéresse
dit la différence voilà le président
voit ça souvent côte-à-côte 0 nicolas
sarkozy a été président de la république
va peut-être que ça avait échappé à
certains mais a été présente la règle et
donc il a un statut d'ancien président
qui fait qu'il est invité un certain
nombre de cérémonies ou oui ça lui
arrive de croiser le président d'un pays
clés nous sommes en république on a
droit de se côtoyer un droit de se
parler au moins ont-ils parlé à votre
avis
du social et regarde ça les regarde la
présidentielle ne me regarde pas et je
ne pense pas que ça vous regarde non
plus derrière petite question j'ai une
dernière petite 45 parmi les phrases
choc on en parle est prononcé par
nicolas sarkozy il ya eu celle sur le
réchauffement climatique qui a beaucoup
fait parler vous même vous aviez créé la
polémique en février en assurant que les
républicains devaient être le parti des
gaz de schiste est ce que vous confirmez
aujourd'hui ces propos j'ai dit que le
party les républicains devaient être le
parti de l'innovation les états unis
d'amérique les gaz de schiste les ouïes
les états unis d'amérique sont devenus
le lidl ou autonome en matière
pétrolière une ressource énergétique
grâce au gaz et pétrole de schiste
ça aurait pu nous interpeller voilà
plutôt que d'interdire par prince en
train de renoncer au loin je suis pour
les recherches
ça n'est pas vrai ils sont pas en train
de renoncer rapidement simplement il ya
un problème de compétitivité par rapport
au prix moyen mondial du pétrole
moi j'ai surtout bien sûr je suis pour
les recherches
mais c'est pour les recherches parce
qu'on est un grand pays d'innovation et
que à force de sur tous les sujets d'un
dans la logique de la précaution on fait
peut rien merci c'est le mot de la fin
sujet merci à vous merci à tous très
bonne semaine on se retrouve bon droit
du prochain